[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
all right what's your name
george
jordan
floyd a second officer charge in the
death of george floyd takes the stand in
federal court plus that was you know his
need kind of like his or his you know
signature decades after a string of
grisly homicides famed fbi profiler john
douglas revisits the case and it's
obvious that they were desperate
uh
to hide someone for two years a child to
lie to the police every time they came
to the house and ask questions a now
six-year-old girl is found safe two
years after she's reported missing but
first the death of amir lok the problem
is that we are living in a nation that
does not deal with us equally funeral
services are held for the 22 year old
black man long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin two weeks after amir lok was shot
and killed by police the 22 year old
minnesota man is laid to rest hundreds
of people came out to celebrate locke's
life and call for change including civil
rights attorney ben crump and renowned
activist reverend al sharpton
locke was shot and killed on february
2nd of this year body camera footage
shows what happened when police entered
an apartment with a no-knock warrant
lock was sleeping on the couch at his
cousin's apartment when officers came
inside locke grabbed a nearby gun later
records shows he was a legal gun owner
after that an officer shoots locke
he died as a result of his injuries at
the time police were searching for
locke's 17 year old cousin makai speed
who was wanted for murder speed has
since been arrested and charged locke's
name was not listed on the warrant his
death has since prompted a call for no
knock warrants to be banned across the
country on thursday he was eulogized by
ben crump and reverend al sharpton both
called for change
what can we do
to make sure our children don't become a
hashtag
well we got to stand up we got to speak
up and we got to fight for our children
we got to fight like they life depend on
it because they life do depend on it it
didn't matter
that amir's name wasn't on the want
because we don't have a right to a name
in the eyes of some in this country
we are nameless suspects when they got
to amir's daughter of the night they
didn't check the wine it don't matter
it's a black man's house he's a nameless
suspect
every one of us
is a dog breakdown away
from nameless suspects
joining us today is l.a county deputy
public defender philip dube and terry
austin philip we know the lock wasn't a
target of this warrant they were
actually looking for his cousin
is there a way to make these warrants
safer or must they go all together
well the only way you're going to make
them safer is to either absolutely
mandate
the knock requirement the knock and
announce or i think there has to be a
very serious discussion on capitol hill
where the house and the senate really
sits and decides whether or not to amend
the constitution and decide what if any
level of force is allowed when executing
a search or an arrest warrant keep in
mind uh brian and terry that the cna
cuandone if you will of the search
warrant was to prevent the the imminent
destruction of evidence particularly in
the 60s and the 70s when drugs were
being flushed down a toilet or thrown
out a window etc you know nowadays
there's less of a concern about
destruction of drugs and more of a
concern about saving human life
especially when we have the uh
exponential loss of minority the the
black and brown lives
at the hands of law enforcement who do
not
knock before they force entry into a
property merely to execute a search or
an arrest warrant
terry as we listen to the words of those
who lost emir lock what stuck out most
to you
well you know philip makes some
excellent points but the speakers made
it very clear that this issue is
actually bigger than a no knock warrant
it's about the issue of race when it
comes to people of color police often
shoot first and then they ask questions
later they assume that black men and
women are dangerous they presume that
they are guilty before they are even
arrested and so at the hands of police
we've seen so many of these innocent
people killed
change has to come through civil and
criminal liability all right locke's
funeral was held in the same church
where services were given for dante
wright who was also killed by a
minnesota police officer just 10 months
earlier on friday kim potter an
ex-police officer convicted in wright's
death is set to be sentenced
prosecutors now say they're seeking a
seven-year sentence for the former
minnesota officer potter shot and killed
wright an unarmed black man during a
traffic stop last april in december a
jury convicted her of first and second
degree manslaughter the state previously
wanted potter to receive a higher
sentence based on aggravating factors in
the case including arguing her actions
posed a danger to the passenger in
wright's car when the shooting happened
potter's defense team in turn have
requested probation as well as a shorter
sentence potter is set to be sentenced
friday morning
switching now to florida where the state
rests in the trial for retired police
captain curtis reeves reece is accused
of shooting and killing chad olson back
in 2014 inside a movie theater after he
says olson refused to put his phone away
the two got into an argument and reeve
says he shot olson in self-defense he
claims olson threw a cell phone at him
despite several witnesses testifying
that didn't happen the state called its
final witness thursday the lead
detective told the jury it would be
difficult to use a phone as a weapon and
cause death with one but said anything
is possible one eyewitness testified to
seeing olson grab popcorn from reeves
and flip it back in his face but said he
didn't see him climb towards reeves or
throw a punch when prosecutors asked
about the altercation between reeves and
olsen another eyewitness told the jury
he didn't hear anything that would
suggest reeves was being violently
attacked the defense will call its first
witness friday
also in florida both sides rest in the
trial of accused serial killer robert
hayes hayes is accused of killing three
women in daytona beach in 2005 and 2006.
authorities say all victims were sex
workers a decade later hayes dna was
linked to the shooting deaths when
another woman was murdered in west palm
beach florida after the state rested
hayes defense team called his first
witness thursday afternoon asking about
the tire impressions gathered at the
crime scenes defense attorneys called a
dna analyst to explain how long dna can
exist to be tested closing arguments are
expected to be presented monday morning
after that jury deliberations will begin
next tuesday
still ahead on law and crime daily famed
serial killer profiler and fbi agent
john douglas revisits the historic case
but first two years after she went
missing a six-year-old girl is found
hiding under a staircase we hear from
the chief of police next on crime daily
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury bonds
[Music]
welcome back we're learning more about
how police in socrates new york found a
six-year-old girl who'd been missing for
two years hiding under a staircase a tip
led pleased to paisley schultes on
valentine's day she was found under a
staircase in the home of her grandfather
kirk schultes hiding with her biological
mother police say kimberly schultes took
paisley after a family court determined
she and her husband kirk schultz jr were
not fit to care for her and her sister
all three schultes are charged with
endangering the welfare of a child and
custodial interference police chief
joseph sinaga sinagra said they'd been
to the home a dozen times looking for
paisley he described exactly how she was
found
and lo and behold an hour and a half
into the search warrant they did locate
paisley and kimberly hiding in that
space
off of paisley's bedroom there's a door
that goes from her bedroom that
immediately accesses the location where
the staircase is
um and that staircase takes you out to
the backyard and it was that particular
staircase where they found paisley and
kimberly
one of our detectives had shined the
light
through a crack that was in the wood
between the step
and the riser he saw what he thought was
a blanket
and they started to take the stairs
apart
and at first they saw a tiny little feet
as they said and as he removed more of
the steps
from the staircase
they found paisley and paisley's mother
secreted in that location
chief sanagara says paisley was happy to
see her custodial parents and sister
when they were reunited he said paisley
told them she cannot read or write and
has not been to school
let's bring back l.a county deputy
public defender philip dube and terry
austin for the latest in the rescue of
paisley schultes terry what's your
reaction to the police chief's interview
on this case we're learning a lot more
from it
well it's sad and it's disturbing it's
sad because we know that this young girl
was taken from her custodial home and
she was taken away from her parents
originally because they were deemed not
to be fit then we know that they came to
the home the authorities did a dozen
times i don't understand why it took two
years for them to finally get a search
warrant we know that the birth parents
have been suspects for all of this time
and in my opinion they should have done
a thorough shirt from the very beginning
i think they would have had grounds for
a warrant to do exactly that so the good
news brian here is that she was well
cared for the bad news is she's really
going to have some psychological issues
here she hasn't been to school she
doesn't read and write so it's a
difficult case yeah the well-care for it
and the school partner is the part
that's going to be interesting from a
legal perspective philip looking at the
custodian interference charge that's the
top charge even though it's a low-level
felony the prosecution has to prove
paisley's safety was
endangered or her health was impaired
what about that story or what about this
story sorry proves that
i think the problem that the prosecution
is going to have is that the uh the
grabamine of that charge is that this
child was either abused abandoned or
neglected in some tangible way and if i
recall the new york statute is not so
much concerned about psychological harm
as it is with physical medical
and similar types of harm and there's
just no evidence that this child was
physically imperiled in any way now
absent some proof that when they found
the child that she was caged in a
situation where she maybe had injury as
a result of it or the parents did in
fact abuse abandon or neglect her in a
tangible way uh you know then obviously
they're in pretty serious criminal
trouble but the way i see this right now
i think the felony is over filed and
really what they should be doing is
going after them for violating that
custody order and depriving the legal
guardian of their rights to custody of
the child yeah we'll see how this case
plays out of course as we said all three
are arrested of course they also have
that endangering the welfare of a child
i think that's going to probably stick
that's the the one that looks strongest
to me but we'll keep following this case
as it develops coming up on law and
crime daily a second x minnesota police
officer takes the stand in his own
defense what jay alexander king tells a
federal jury under oath plus renowned
fbi agent john douglas revisits a
notorious case he talks serial killers
murderer profiles and the behavioral
analyst unit still ahead
[Music]
welcome back a decorated fbi agent
revisits a notorious case digging deeper
inside the mind of a serial killer he
once confronted as long crime daily
sierra gillespie explains retired agent
john douglas is more than just a
profiler but a modern-day storyteller
brian one-time fbi agent john douglas
went from profiling serial killers to
new york times number one best seller as
it turns out the man who inspired
netflix's mind hunter series has a
series of stories himself you know the
work of john douglas whether you're
familiar with the name or not in fact
jody foster you could search on youtube
getting her oscar she'll thank john
douglas
of the fbi 1991 1992.
john douglas and everybody at quantico
the incredible cast and crew of silence
and the lambs it was a fictional serial
killer that flung this renowned fbi
agent into the cultural zeitgeist
it was douglas's real life work that
inspired it all i would go in there and
i would know the case backwards force
upside you know down every every which
way and it kind of impressed them
because when they started to kind of try
to pull the wool over my eyes i said hey
come on
knock off the bs here i said that didn't
happen that way it doesn't have and they
would laugh and even charles mass would
laugh you heard that right douglas the
original mind hunter sat face to face
with some of the most notorious serial
killers in history jeffrey dahmer
committed insane acts this big guy ed
kemper six foot nine three hundred pound
guy dennis raider the btk strangler who
i interviewed david burke was the son of
sam ted funding but the latest case
douglas has chosen to revisit
stands out for a different reason this
is not a hoax call it's really
risk-taking on their part he was putting
these these this family the first family
through the paces so that was that was
you know his need kind of like his or
his you know signature that signature
came in the form of repeated phone calls
to dawn smith the sister of missing
17-year-old sherry smith
smith was last seen in may 1985 getting
the mail outside her south carolina home
later a cryptic letter arrives in sherry
smith's handwriting i never had a case
where after the abduction
the subject makes the victim
write the last swollen testament
and she's saying goodbye to her
family uh and uh she wants a closed
casket
and
he calls the family up and tell him did
you get the last old testament when
nine-year-old deborah may helmet went
missing weeks later the phone calls
continued but not to helmick's family
dawn looked exactly like sheri
smithfield exactly like her and he did
speak to her on the on the phone but but
so it's just it's just these crimes are
crimes of power in control there's a
usually yeah there'll be a sexual
component but it's really power and
control manipulation domination you know
and control and that's that's what he
was doing the sherry smith and deborah
hellmick's stories are the subject of
douglas's latest book when a killer
calls and while douglas says a case like
that is difficult to cover the rewards
you get you know that the people who
write me letters to this day or through
facebook or young kids or older people
who
threw a book or heard me speak how it
helped it helped them and helped them in
their lives and that's the
the rewarding part in the end it's the
real life monsters that scare douglas
the most the lead hannibal lecter guy
that guy uh you know doesn't exist thank
goodness i mean we can you know get out
of handcuffs and all that i really don't
like it because in the movies you got
that scary music in the background i
mean on a crime scene there's no music
for that music i can't stand that that
music the background so i don't i don't
watch any violent violent shows in
theaters douglas's latest book when a
killer calls is available now for long
crime daily i'm sierra gillespie
when we come back 3x officer stand trial
in federal court for the death of george
floyd defendant jay alexander king takes
the stand in his own defense our legal
analysts break down that testimony after
this
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
witness testifies in federal court to
the that two of the three men convicted
in the death of a mod arbory sent text
messages with racist slurs in them
before aubry's death father and son
gregory and trousman michael along with
neighbor william roddy bryan all face
federal hate crime charges in aubry's
death on wednesday an fbi intelligence
analyst took the stand telling jurors
traveling michael sent a 2019 text
message using the n-word saying quote
they ruined everything the analyst also
testified brian sent a message
containing derogatory slurs about
african-american features last year all
three men were convicted in aubrey's
murder in a georgia state court trial
all three men were sentenced to life in
prison brian is eligible for parole
after 30 years served the mcmichaels
will serve 20 years on top of their life
sentence prosecutors say aubry a 25 year
old black man was going for a jog near
his brunswick georgia home when the
mcmichaels began tailing him in a pickup
truck traffic michael eventually shot
and killed aubry claiming has since
repealed and replaced citizen's arrest
law brian captured the incident on his
cell phone
also in federal court a second
ex-officer takes the stand as three
defendants are charged in the death of
george floyd two tao thomas slain and
jay alexander king all face charges for
depriving floyd of his rights in may
2020 tu tau was the first former officer
in the trial to take the stand in his
own defense on wednesday and thursday
federal jurors heard from a second
ex-cop jay alexander king king told
jurors he was trained to follow the
quote chain of command in the police
department deferring to orders from the
mpd veteran derek shovin king testified
shovin was a senior officer and that he
trusted shovin's advice last year
sheldon was convicted in floyd's murder
in state court and has pled guilty to
violating floyd's civil rights in
federal court king later told jurors he
didn't think the 911 call about george
floyd seemed serious at first he said
things escalated when trying to get
floyd into the police suv king's body
camera footage from the day shows what
happened as officers attempted to take
floyd into custody
[Music]
floyd later died at the hospital after
becoming unconscious while chauvin knelt
on his neck for over nine minutes the
third ex-officer facing federal charges
thomas lane is expected to take the
stand next week
philip king took the stand with the i
was following orders defense is that
going to hold up with these charges
i think it really depends because the
scope of the necessary intervention the
physical intervention measures have to
be clearly delineated in the policies
practices and procedures manual that
these officers are given in training not
to mention clearly delineated at least
by the eighth circuit court of appeals
where minnesota is situated and from
my understanding based on my research is
that the law is a little murky as to how
far they need to go because what if
hypothetically
george floyd would have survived
and maybe officer king would have taken
an elbow or used a little mma or pushed
chauvin
you know lane could have been
disciplined terminated or maybe even
prosecuted for that behavior so at what
point and what may they rely on in
determining whether or not they have
properly or improperly intervened
absolutely well we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you